public sénat en partenariat avec afp
les échos radio classique présente le
bras droit d' emmanuel macron et même
son guerrier c'est ainsi que l'on
présente notre invité cette semaine
richard ferrand bonsoir vous êtes le
secrétaire général désormais de la
république en marche si vous suivez le
président élu depuis depuis ses débuts
depuis son engagement pour cette
présidentielle
merci donc d'être présent à ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec life
paix avec les échos et radio classique
un moment clé et même crucial 1 c cap
sur les législatives
trois grandes questions bien sûr au
cours de cette émission quelle majorité
demain entraînée par quel premier
ministre jérémy marot vous le demandera
dans un instant quelle réforme
rapidement pour répondre à la crise
sociale mais sans provoquer une levée de
boucliers des syndicats notamment qui se
mobilisent déjà question que vous posera
jean-francis pécresse enfin quel
président sera emmanuel macron la marche
du louvre donne déjà peut être une idée
mais vous en dirai plus tout à l'heure à
un mickaël szames s mais d'abord une
première question d'actualité
[Musique]
manuel valls annonce donc sa candidature
aux législatives au nom de la nouvelle
majorité présidentielle il va devoir
bien sûr respecter la procédure
le temps presse puisque il doit le faire
d'ici demain mais vous vous richard
ferrand est ce que vous voyez la
candidature de manuel valls comme un
atout ou comme un poids
tout d'abord je crois qu'il faut prendre
cette nouvelle pour ce qu'elle est c'est
un ancien premier ministre donc une
personnalité éminente qui juge que la
démarche des manuels macron et celle que
nous poursuivons est donc la bonne pour
la france
donc moi j'en prends acte avec
satisfaction ensuite pour le reste s'il
souhaite être candidat aux législatives
et singulièrement investi par la
république en marche et il faut qu'il
matérialise sa candidature que la
commission nationale d'investiture que
préside jean paul delevoye s'en
saisissent et jeudi avant midi
vous avez leur avoue avoir également un
souhait un voeu est ce que vous le
souhaitez voir investie est ce que vous
me dire oui ou non écoutez vous savez
tout ça n'est pas le fait d'une ou autre
une autre personnalité c'est un ensemble
nous avons posé des critères nous
voulons plus de 50% qui de temps et le
candidat guy proviennent de la société
civile respecter la parité le pluralisme
et c'est alors si la démarche de manuel
valls trouve sa place dans cet ensemble
de critères
je ne vois pas a priori d'inconvénient
merdes inconvénients mais vous y mettez
des cinémas comme si ça n'était pas
automatique vous l'avez dit un ancien
premier ministre et rien n'est
automatique moi j'ai déposé ma
candidature je ne suis pas encore
investi à l'heure qu'il est on est pas
encore mais sur le fond manuel valls est
tout à fait ma cro cop est compatible
vous êtes d'accord il a appelé à voter
pour lui oui non je crois qu'il faut il
faut examiner les ses motivations les
termes les termes de sa candidature
voilà à faire ce que l'on fait pour tout
le monde alors immanuel macron dans le
documentaire de tf1 qui était diffusé
hier soir que vous avez sans doute
regarder traite
manuel valls de traître un traître à
hollande responsable d'un impeachment
sans prise de risque personnel ajoutait
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron vous avez
noté la formule est ce que vous craignez
donc sur le considèrent comme un traître
à danger de manque de loyauté de sa part
demain alors avec les normes est mais il
ne faut pas faire de procès d'intention
à qui que ce soit son trépas très
bienveillant non ce que je crois si vous
voulez c'est que là la phrase d'
emmanuel macron et pour tout vous dire
je n'ai pas eu le temps de regarder le
documentaire je voulais rapportés mais
je le traître je sens que je vous en
fils de risques personnels
on y va c'est une manière de dire à
l'époque pour remettre les choses dans
leur contexte j'imagine c'était à cette
époque là que emmanuel macron avait reçu
de la part d'anciens premiers ministres
un certain nombre de leçons morales en
disant que lui-même avait trahi que
c'était une démarche solitaire enfin
vous vous souvenez que une candidature
de s'improviser par un certain nombre
d'amabilités liées au contexte ben et au
fond ensuite l'analyse qu'a fait mme
nelles macron ça a été de dire si j'en
crois cette phrase ça et c'est à dire
que finalement lui il a démissionné
emmanuel macron il a démissionné la
fonction publique qu'il a créé son
mouvement et il a proposé de nouvelles
offres politiques aux fractions on avait
compris qu'il se sait que conséquent un
vie n'était pas dans une logique de
rester au sein de l'exécutif pour
ensuite jouer des coudes pour être
candidat différencier c'est ce qu'il a
voulu dire effectivement dans ses
commentaires
le ps est mort a dit également
aujourd'hui manuel valls où il est mort
pour bossi a coûté il paraître en villa
il à plusieurs ça y est la main de
candidats il a manifestement encore t'es
des gens qui veulent mener la bagarre
des législatives qui ont déclaré une
plate forme donc cru qui résistent à la
tentation macro en tout cas il n'est pas
en grande forme mais il est pas mort au
foot et moi je n'aime pas comme ça
proclamait des actes de décès je préfère
voir la république en marche en vigueur
mais ça m'intéresse plus le ps est mort
pour vous personnellement vous avez
rendu votre carte pour les déchirer ou
ça y est non je dis
20 vu le niveau de responsabilité qui
étaient les miennes il était logique que
je n'adhère plus au parti socialiste
mais elle sans tambour ni trompette
d'accord donc vous n'êtes plus membre
évidemment du parti soucier de piquant
précisément quelques jours depuis
quelques jours la voilà si je vais
prendre le temps j'en ai pas eu beaucoup
de rencontrer avant d'officialiser les
choses
celles et ceux avec qui depuis bien
longtemps je milite et qui sont devenus
en bretagne et singulièrement dans le
finistère mes amis et qu'il faut qu'il
faut compter à nouveau évidemment dans
les semaines qui viennent non seulement
ça mais ce sont deux amis dont l'un des
amis on leur explique ce qu'on fait
pourquoi ils ont compris depuis un
moment à vous concernant certains enfin
la suite avec jérémie moreau de la fp
qui nous rejoint donc et on va rester
sur la question des législatives
l'épreuve de vérité avec la fp
bonsoir jérémy soir michel bonsoir
monsieur ferrand alors je dis vous
présenterez le jeudi avant midi vous
présenterez les 577 candidats qui
doivent composer la majorité
présidentielle alors par est il qu'ils
aient eu énormément de coups de fil de
dernière minute des parlementaires des
députés qui soudainement se disent ah
tiens il faudrait que j'en vois un
formulaire en marche
c'est exact là vous monsieur gros sur
viens de parler du plus célèbre d'entre
eux mais il est vrai que il y a des
vocations tardives qui s'éveille et
qu'est ce que vous leur dites à ces
vocations tardives will est ce que j'ai
répondu à monsieur grossiord c il était
temps il va falloir varié où un peu la
commission d'investiture va s'en saisir
et puis on vous dira ce qu'on en pense
et parmi eux il ya beaucoup il y aura
des déçus forcément vous savez il y a un
peu plus de 15000 ce que c'est pas moi
qui suis ça directement mais en vain
plus de 15000 candidates et candidats
mais qui savent bien entendu que seuls
c'est le nombre de circonscriptions
seront retenus donc les règles du jeu
sont claires depuis le début que cela
passe par une commission nationale
d'investiture c'est connu les critères
sont connus donc il n'y aura pas de
surprises en tout cas peut-être y
aura-t-il des déçus parce que quand on
candidate à quelque chose et qu'on n'ait
pas retenu c'est la vie tous une pointe
de déception
bon mais cela étant les choses auront
été fait dans la transparence dans les
règles et sous l'autorité de jean paul
delevoye est plus plus sérieusement vous
sentez il ya un petit vin chaud sur ie
vous serez mairie un petit vent de
panique non quand même à gauche on se
dit là il est temps de voir rejoindre
c'est la dernière chance dernier wagon
oui mais nous on ne lit pas comme ça
s'il voulait nous nous voulons vous
savez il faut pas oublier une chose en
marche repose sur deux jambes en marche
sur deux jambes
le rassemblement et le renouvellement et
moi je suis garant que ces deux
promesses soient tenues
le rassemblement ça veut dire à la fois
des citoyens engagés dans différentes
sensibilités et qui se retrouve dans le
projet porté par emmanuel macron et le
renouvellement
cela veut dit
que des personnes qui avaient jusque-là
des mandats locaux ou pas demander du
doubs doivent venir s'investir dans la
vie politique et donc je suis comme
secrétaire général le garant de ces deux
promesses fondatrice religieusement et
je puis vous dire que nous serons tenus
le renouvellement implique des gens qui
ont déjà eu des mandats en fait mais
localement
lorsque nous nous avons dix 50% de la
société civile oui nous disons par
conséquent que 50 % d'autres sont d'une
manière ou d'une autre
engagé dans la vie politique mais
souvent la vie politique locale conseil
départemental municipal régional maire
que sais-je voilà ça fait d'accord parmi
parmi qu'on serait bien clair les
représentants de la société civile il
n'y aura aucun élu actuelle c'est ça
aucun mandat de leur côté à la dallas
éclat et ce seront potentiellement des
personnes qui auront eu déjà un mandat
par le passé c'est possible si quelqu'un
a 50 ans et qu'entre 25 et 30 ans il a
été conseiller municipal vous le
classerait où vous voudrez dans la
société civile ou politique mais enfin
ce n'est pas non plus ce n'est pas un
exercice de police il faut quand on fait
de la politique c'est l'état d'esprit
l'état d'esprit c'est de dire des gens
qui aujourd'hui ont une activité
professionnelle entrepreneuriale
associative libérales etc bref qui ne
sont pas des professionnels de la
politique vont être la moitié de nos
représentants et dans l'autre moitié il
y aura sans doute quelques
parlementaires
d'expérience je suis moi-même
parlementaires sortants et j'ai demandé
l'investiture et il y aura des élus
locaux qui justement apporteront leur
expérience d'élu car l'enjeu c'est que
cette majorité soit un alliage à la fois
des forces économiques sociales
syndicales associatives mais aussi de
femmes et d'hommes qui ont des pratiques
de politiques publiques qui une certaine
expérience de la vie politique donc le
renouvellement doit se faire de cette
manière en bonnart est ce que les
électeurs auront dans le temps de
prendre en fait connaissance de la
dimension personnelle de ses candidats
venus de la société civile des inconnus
que vous dites est ce que c'est pas un
risque là que vous courrez dans ses
vocalises et même si emmanuel macron sur
la fiche
évidemment en gros oui c'est vous qui
dites que ce sont des inconnus mais vous
savez pour la plupart ce sont des gens
qui font campagne depuis le 16
vambre pour emmanuel macron qui dans
chaque chef-lieu de canton dans les
communes de leur territoire rione
important le projet la candidature
d'emmanuel magron ce ne sont pas des
gens sorti d'un chapeau
par conséquent la population a déjà
repéré que madame untel monsieur untel
ou autres sans les engagés pour la
candidature d'emmanuel macron donc après
on dira ah bah oui ben non ils sont
investis cas vous former la majorité
alors vous le le mouvement marche plein
depuis sa création pour la transparence
peut être qu'il est temps de vous dire
combien de circonscriptions sont
réservés aux au modem finalement alors
vous pourrez le détectée jeudi avant
midi
mais en vérité on veut pas rentrer dans
cette idée qu'il y aurait une pesée au
trébuchet ce n'est pas sale état
d'esprit l'état d'esprit est pourquoi y
at il eu avec le modem est qu'avec le
modem
un accord de cette nature c'est parce
que monsieur bayrou avait la capacité la
légitimité l'histoire pour être candidat
à la présidence de la république
il a donc proposé de renoncer à sa
candidature au bénéfice d'une alliance
en disant qu'il souhaitait que cette
alliance se fasse à la fois dans un
souci de représentativité de sa
sensibilité et dans l'indépendance du
mouvement en marche que emmanuel macron
a créé bon voilà les conditions de
l'accord et ce qui a été dit en même
temps par nous et par lui c'est que nous
voulons sacrifier aucun talent émergent
aucune candidature nouvelles sous
prétexte que la personne ne serait pas
modem pur sucre si je puis dire donc les
choses doivent se faire en bonne
intelligence pour que les meilleures
candidates et les meilleurs candidats
par consensus émerge et porte toute la
bannière la république en marche
donc les choses se font en bonne
intelligence et jeudi il sera temps de
constater les termes de l'accord de
celles et ceux qui voudront figuré
ensuite dans le monde et notamment voir
également ceux qui viennent de la droite
en est sans gâcher l'effet de surprise
dit nous est ce que je dis on verra des
députés de droite venant de la droite
dans les 577 nom que vous passez des
députés actuellement en sortant voilà
écoutez il se peut qu'il y en a
quelques-uns oui comme il y aura
quelques députés socialistes si pour
l'instant vous voyez que du coup l'effet
de renouvellement sera beaucoup plus
ample que le sait que nous avons fixés
car ils ne sont pas si nombreux
finalement pour l'instant voilà il n'y
avait qu'un parlementaire qui vous a
officiellement rejoint ce le sénateur
jean baptiste lemoyne mais aucun député
expliquez-nous quels sont les freins
mais parmi nos candidats vous trouverez
des élus locaux qui qui sont le
sensibilité de droite ça vous mais
pourquoi les députés de droite et si
vous ne connaissez pas ou on voulait
montrera parce que vous comprenez il ya
un truc que je trouve étrange depuis la
création du mouvement en marche on me
dit je vais enfin quels sont vos
soutiens parlementaires comme si la vie
politique en france se faisait selon le
nombre de parlementaires qui soutiennent
pierre ou paul
je ne crois pas à regarder benoît hamon
avait beaucoup de parlementaires qui
l'avaient soutenu monsieur mélenchon
avait beaucoup moins monsieur macro
encore moins bon vous connaissez les
résultats
donc si vous voulez nous j'essaye depuis
plus d'un an d'expliquer que ce n'est
pas ça l'essentiel
d'accord mais l'essentiel pour vous
c'est de décrocher la majorité absolue
est ce que vous êtes convaincus de
l'obtenir
sachant que les observateurs considèrent
que ce serait de la part du président
élu un nouvel exploit une nouvelle
mission impossible
est ce que vous êtes toujours convaincu
oui oui oui je suis convaincu que nous
sommes capables je ne vous dis pas que
nous allons réussir
c'est comme quand emmanuel macron était
candidat je disais moi je j'ai la
conviction que nous avons avec capacité
d'y arriver mais on verra quoi ce sont
quand même les électrices et les
électeurs qui décident mais moi ce que
je crois c'est que les électrices et les
électeurs n'ont pas élu emmanuel macron
pour qu'il a inauguré avec les en pleine
arrivée les chiffres c'est pour qu'ils
m'en ont dit qu'il n'y a pas un vote
massif d'adhésion qu'il ya 4 millions de
blancs et 2 nuls ces sont des critères
importants qui peut-être que vous
inquiéter oui évidemment il faut d'abord
il faut c'est pas ton des inquiétudes
que du respect pour ceux qui ont voulu
exprimer
leur non adhésion au mans vous allez à
leur parler alors cette manière là mais
avant jouent leur taille même vous
rappeler qu emmanuel macron a obtenu
plus de voix que françois hollande que
nicolas sarkozy georges pompidou
de sorte qu'on ne peut pas quand même
pas nous raconter qu'il aurait une
élection ric-rac 66%
moi je signe tous les jours pour gagner
une élection ce niveau là bonds est par
ailleurs en nombre de deux citoyennes et
citoyens qui ont voté pour lui si on
rapporte la propension au nombre des
inscrits
c'est mieux que les trois présidents que
je viens de citer donc qu'on nous fasse
pas ce coup là bon après il nous faudra
expliquer à la fois jusque dans le
détail à nouveau le projet que nous
portons le contrat avec la nation et ce
sera le boulot des candidates et des
candidats d'expliquer ce projet du
premier ministre du premier ministre
bien entendu et ensuite de dire le
président n'est pas là pour ne pas agir
donc il faut donner au président les
moyens d'action les moyens ça s'appelle
une majorité à l'assemblée nationale et
je constate que depuis 81 le peuple
français ne s'est jamais démenti donc il
n'y a pas de raison de spéculer devait
faire un un horoscope particulièrement
sombre pour cette année 2010 est d'ici
là justement d'ici les législatives
comment parler à l'électorat de droite
on voit bien que dans la structure de
l'électorat monsieur macron ça penche à
gauche et que c'est dans cet électorat
de droite qui est peut-être plus mobile
que là il faut aller chercher et 1 des
voix est arrivé à leur parler quand les
séduire or je préfère convaincre que
séduire en matière politique convaincre
simplement en d'abord par cette logique
institutionnelle et je crois que
beaucoup de françaises et de français
qui sont de sensibilité de droite n'ont
pas envie de bazar ils prennent acte que
le président est élu
bon certains sont contents d'autres le
sont moins mais ils se disent après tout
puisqu'il est choisie faut qu'il puisse
agir
je crois qu'il y ait une très forte
aspiration dans notre pays à la
cohérence de l'action politique
la fronde d'où qu'elles viennent je
crois que l'on concitoyens en ont juste
eu ras-le-bol donc beaucoup de gens vous
savez je vois beaucoup de gens dans mes
déplacements dans la circonscription du
finistère intérieur entre
car et crozon et château là quand je
discute avec les gens disent maintenant
un président il faut qu'il fasse ce
qu'il a à faire
en espérant que ça marchera et c'est ça
le bon sens français c'est pas de
chercher des combinazione compliqué quel
projet politique porté par monsieur
baroin je ne sais quelle autre ticket
alimentation y militent pour une classe
que j'arrive donc servir qu ils lisent
en français bon écoutez vous avez voté
pour monsieur macro parfait mais
maintenant changé tout est voté pour une
majorité bloquante bon mais ce n'est pas
sérieux dans un français ne souhaitent
de blocage alors l'oiseau rare pour
matignon
vous l'avez trouvée ah ça c'est une
compétence exclusive du président de la
république et nous a pas échappé que
c'est pas moi il faut quand même donner
des gages à l'électorat de droite est
peut-être en faisant rentrer dès la
semaine prochaine des ministres de
droite voire le premier ministre bien je
transmettrai votre conseil au président
de la république côté du conseil qui
vous paraît pertinent vous savez moi je
transmets je ne suis que le le
vaguemestre des conseils des uns et des
autres et vous qui connaissez
parfaitement le paysage politique
français dit nous est ce qu'il y a des
des poids lourds de la droite qui vous
paraissent compatible avec le projet que
vous portez mais plus sérieusement si
vous voulez pas vous y répondez à la
question on va c'est la réponse que je
qualifie plus sérieuse non plus
sérieusement ce que je veux vous dire
c'est que depuis le début
emmanuel macron prône le rassemblement
et une majorité qui relève d'une
pluralité d'origine de citoyennes
citoyens et de personnalités politiques
dont vous faut il a déjà affirmé
on retrouvera dans son gouvernement la
pluralité de sensibilité et la présence
de personnalités de la société civile
il l'a dit en meeting l'une faut deux
bons donc il n'y a pas de raison qu'ils
deviennent pas sa parole très bien mais
plutôt une personnalité de droite à
matignon vous êtes actif je ne suis
vraiment pas non si je vous le dit vrai
si je le savais je vous dirais messieurs
grosse cure pas de raisons que je vous
fasse des cachotteries d'accord et ça
pourrait être vous un papa personnalités
de droite je veux dire mais à matignon
vous sentez comment dans cette position
savez peut-être parmi les favoris la la
la short list votre nom un jour alors il
faut jamais croire ce qu'on lit dans la
presse a offert attention pour ça qu'on
vous pose la question directement non
mauvaise verrier devait bouger ans moi
je veux dire quand je me suis engagé aux
côtés d' emmanuel macron depuis le début
c'est parce qu'en conscience et à
l'époque on n'était pas nombreux
je peux vous le dire en conscience
j'avais la conviction que son élection
et serait la meilleure pour la france
parce que c'est un homme qui à la fois
pour une vision et des solutions aux
problèmes des français
le fait que nous ayons collectivement
alors nous avons été des centaines de
milliers à aider mais que nous ayons
réussi à convaincre nos compatriotes et
qu emmanuel macron soit élu aujourd'hui
est que maintenant on travaille à
conquérir les moyens d'exécuter le
projet est pour moi une satisfaction
totale mais c'est pas l'aboutissement
total non plus à penser déjà à
l'aboutissement dans la fait que
j'aimerais tenir une marche pour vous je
n'ai aucun regret les gros mots
peut-être ça ça compte pas vous la
marque du perron de matignon
ça ne compte pas vous compte pas
beaucoup on verra on verra
merci beaucoup jérémy la suite de
l'épreuve de vérité vêtements et jean
francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique qui nous
rejoint
richard ferrand soir alors qu'elle
grandes réformes sociales
faut-il attendre dans les 100 jours
d'abord vous savez moi je partage l'idée
avec emmanuel macron que cette date des
100 jours période est 100 jours c'est
une date funeste dans l'histoire de
france que s'est mal terminée et pour
que par ailleurs cinq ans et passe en
jour mais enfin je comprends pas qu'on
commence
il y avait chuté et puis après ils
allient que quand même ça avait un sens
de faire de faire assez vite des
réformes que l'on ne fait pas plus tard
surtout tenté de rentrer populaire au
coeur de l'été préférant par exemple
alors nous allons mener une campagne
électorale dans la clarté
donc si nous avons une majorité parce
que nous portons nos réformes c'est pas
qu'elles seront impopulaires c'est que
nous aurons réussi à faire comprendre
qu'elles sont utiles au pays ont fait
pas des réformes pour être impopulaires
ou pour embêter le monde
en effet parce qu'on a la conviction
qu'elles vont servir le pays alors pour
répondre à votre question chantier
numéro un c'est la moralisation de la
vie publique
ça c'est avant les législatives qu'il
faudra examiner
enfin xavier faire adopter ou débattre
en conseil des ministres du gouvernement
c'est le premier texte qui doit venir
c'est un engagement emmanuel macron des
la majorité élue à l'assemblée nationale
manuel macron souhaite que le premier
chantier sera celui de la simplification
du code du travail du droit du travail
et le troisième chantier qui va venir
avant l'été ce sera évidemment de
préparer la rentrée scolaire selon les
règles que nous avons définies notamment
que pour dans les quartiers où on
constate qu'il ya beaucoup d'enfants un
échec on puisse avoir pas plus de douze
enfants devra mettre une maîtresse et
pendant l'été il s'agira de préparer le
budget 2010 vite le premier budget utile
du quinquennat qui intégrera les
différentes réformes fiscales sur
l'impôt sur les sociétés l'impôt sur les
grandes fortunes tels que le candidat
désormais lui a eu l'occasion d'écrire
sur la le calendrier sur l'année la
simplification d'abord donc du travail
du marché du bon du travail
petite question de méthode est ce qu il
est toujours question de procéder par
des ordonnances parce qu'on sent que ce
point fait discussions et fait débat
ferait débat autour de emmanuel macron
donc maintenant qu'on a dit qu'il
souhaitait procéder de la sorte et pour
qui la france aidera de la sorte
bella n'a jamais démenti son intention
il l'a répété plusieurs fois
alors on nous oppose à ça parce qu'il
faut aller au bout du sujet on dit bon
enfin les on commence ça interdit la
concertation c'est brutal
c'est ce que disent les syndicats il le
répète encore aujourd'hui oui j'ai bien
vu ça sauf que sauf que aujourd'hui à
l'occasion de la loi travail précédente
les différents rapports différentes
études pour combrexelle etc etc ont été
produits donc on les connaît on connaît
les préoccupations des organisations
syndicales
bon donc ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que la concertation pourra avoir lieu
évidemment et elle aura lieu mais qu'on
ne souhaite pas que le débat
parlementaire s'enlise
c'est pourquoi on souhaite elle évite
non pas pour ce quiz et si je peux avoir
le mans expression pas très joli
pardonnez-moi les syndicats mais alors
les syndicats mais pour aller plus vite
dans la procédure parlementaire
c'est ça l'état d'esprit quand donc il
faut le comprendre comme ça c'est allé
vite du point de vue de la procédure
parlementaire et prendre le temps de la
discussion avec l'ensemble des
partenaires sociaux
il ya entre autres dans cette réforme un
point que les français n'aiment pas mais
manifestement pas du tout c'est cette
idée de plafonner les indemnités
prud'homale c'est à dire de mettre dans
le contrat de travail
le maximum des pénalités dommages et
intérêts auxquels on aurait droit en cas
de licenciement abusif par son employeur
est-ce que vous maintiendrez cette
proposition telle qu'elle est ce qu'elle
est négociable
on savait que c'est un point qui tient à
coeur au président élu vous souvenez
peut-être d'ailleurs que dans la loi
macron dont j'avais été le rapporteur
cette disposition avait naguère été
cassée par le conseil constitutionnel
parce que le niveau d' indemnité était
liée à la taille de l'entreprise mais
j'avais eu l'occasion d'être comme
rapporteur
de dire au gouvernement à l'époque que
c'était stupide puisque chacun sait que
si on se fait renverser par un véhicule
ce n'est pas la grosseur du véhicule qui
justifie la réparation du préjudice mais
la réalité du préjudice que vous avez
subi le gouvernement n'avait pas écouté
le parlement est la même pour ses frais
au conseil constitutionnel vient donc là
l'idée en fait c'est quoi l'idée c'est
de constater premièrement qui vient de
grands écarts sur les dommages intérêts
qui sont accordées selon les
juridictions
il n'ya pas d'homogénéité ensuite c'est
de donner une lisibilité à la fois au
salarié et à l'employeur qui font vivre
et un conflit et faire en sorte qu'on
gagne en homogénéité et en réparation
juste sur la base de la moyenne des
indemnités versées
c'est ça qui est important la réparation
du projet pourquoi enfin chacun se dise
puisque jeu puisque je suis si le
licenciement est reconnue abusif je vais
obtenir au fond la moyenne de ce qui est
versé dans le pays
on peut penser que les procédures vont
diminuer en nombre et vont accélérer en
vitesse et pour faciliter l'embauché en
fait au bout du compte c'est surtout
pour que l'on n'ait pas le sentiment que
lorsqu'il ya un conflit du travail car
beaucoup d'employeurs vous le disent que
lorsqu'on a un conflit du travail on
part pour trois ans de procédures etc en
quelque sorte il n'y a pas de visibilité
sur le goudron ça aussi ce sera maintenu
malgré ce sondage effectivement
défavorable
organisée par les échos et radio
classique sur ce thème voilà par auto
que ça vous voyez monsieur je vous en
prie je pense que ce que la réponse que
je viens de vous apporter méritera
justement de faire partie des
explications qu'il faudra donner aux
gens c'est ça le travail de conviction
qui est le nom le but du jeu c'est pas
de dire on va faire que vous touchiez le
moins possible oui si vous faites
licenciés c'est pas ça le but ce n'est
pas de d'affaiblir les salles arrive à
des positionnements l'essentiel d'abord
une moyenne puisque vous parlez
conviction justement comment est-ce que
vous réagissez aux manifestations qui
ont eu lieu hier à paris au lendemain de
l'élection du président de la république
et qui se veulent and avertissements
sociale l'avertissement est également
celui de jean luc mélenchon vous allez
répondre dans un instant mais je vais
également vous faire écouter tout de
suite eric coquerel des insoumises sur
le même thème effectivement qu'aborde
jean-francis la politique qu'il a
annoncées pour va l'oublier
hier tout ça a été encore une fois un
enrobage pour paquets cadeaux la
politique il annoncé c'est toujours plus
de dérégulation et super lourd travail
il va s'en prendre aux traites
il a annoncé à l'as vence 60 milliards
de plus d'austérité
et c'est cette politique là qu'il va
bien falloir à un moment donné qu'il
présente aux législatives
or depuis hier ce que nous savons c'est
que plus de la majorer plus la moitié
des français
bien plus la moitié français n'ont pas
voté pour lui et dans ceux dans dans son
électorat à peu près la bâtisse son
lectorat sont les études au voter paul
hipster barrage au front national
réagissait s'appelle on entend la
résistance et il quelque chose qui me
gêne beaucoup dans il ya une chose qui
m'étonne et de choses qui me qu'imagine
chose qui m'étonne c'est que monsieur
cochrane n'est pas annoncer l'apocalypse
parce que quand on l'entend on a
l'impression que véritablement il y
aurait des politiques cachées ou autres
pas du tout je voudrais ensuite dire que
nous avons distribué 50 millions de
tracts plus les professions de foi que
nous vous et moi avons reçu dans nos
boîtes aux lettres et à aucun moment les
intentions que nous avons sur ce terrain
là n'ont été dit
mulet et ensuite ce que je trouve très
choquant et kate ont frôlé le propos
factieux c'est ce procès en illégitimité
qui se réfère à l'élection du président
macron est grosso modo en dix ans donc
ok on a voté pour lui parce que le pen
de était dangereuse mais par conséquent
nous sommes fondés à nous opposer à tout
je crois ensuite que cette magnifique
lieu de vous non je vous ai dit que
c'est très propos qui étaient à la
limite de propos factieux je crois qu'il
faut reconnaître le résultat des
élections va commencer par ça laissez le
gouvernement s'installe et le dialogue
social se dérouler et ensuite il y aura
bien sûr je veux bien entendu monsieur
coquerelles et d'autres qui continueront
à raconter linverse ce que nous faisons
en vrai et qui vont essayer de mal
expliqué ce que nous faisons ce que
c'est pas leur rôle
ce sera le nôtre donc à nous de faire ce
travail mais vous voyez bien quand même
qui a un sentiment particulier au
lendemain de cette élection
présidentielle on a le sentiment qu'il
n'y aura pas un état de grâce comme en
général il ya petite période et à grasse
la malle impression qui a pas d'état de
grâce
c'est ce que dit laurent berger jusqu'au
10 leur enverra un courrier le patron de
la cfdt le dit oui mais je vous
expliquer comment de leur sens et leur
santé aussi
c'est à dire que vient les françaises et
les français
clairement estime qu'il faut tourner la
page
d'ailleurs c'est ce que nous leur avons
proposé avec le quinquennat qui s'achève
et même avec 20 ans de pratique
institutionnelle et de politiques qui
n'ont pas réussi donc il y à une
impatience et il y a même chez emmanuel
macron une impatience à agir donc tout
le monde envie d'agir et de mettre en
oeuvre le programme qui est le nôtre
ceci explique sans doute qu' il n'y ait
pas ce sentiment avec des teintes grâce
déjà c'est un concept théologique ce
françois mitterrand avait appliqué à la
vie politique c'est un moment de joie
collective de flottement où tout le
monde était heureux de vivre ensemble on
a très bien compris
que l'acuité l'urgence des problèmes là
multiplient la multiplicité des sujets
auxquels il faut donner des réponses
quasiment en même temps fait qu'il ya
une impatience et pas du tout deux
situations de béatitude collective si
vous voulez où on attend que les choses
se fassent
alors en dehors de la mode de la
moralisation de la vie publique qu'est
ce qui sera mis en oeuvre très
rapidement c'est à dire avant les
élections législatives
eh bien vous savez il restera peu de
temps songé comme un gars tu auras un
mot enfin ils ont un président sera
installé le 14 vous savez que en france
il faut que le conseil d'état dispose
d'au moins quinze jours trois semaines
pour examiner un projet de loi
donc on va commencer par la moralisation
de la vie publique préparer ensuite ce
qui est relatif au droit du travail que
nous avons évoqués et il me semble que
pour mourir pour nourrir le travail
après les élections législatives il y
aura de quoi s'occuper
quand est ce que vous allez réduire le
nombre de parlementaires par exemple
donc à lancer dans les dents ce projet
de loi que soit imposée alors de réduire
le nombre de paris est ce que les
sélections sénatoriales ce prêt se
dérouleront comme prévu rang en
septembre est ce qu'il faut aller
ailleurs mais aurait porté l'information
sur cette idée de report une question
une réponse vraiment très rapide est ce
que la baisse de l'impôt sur les sur les
grandes fortunes de lits sfs qu'elle
interviendra dès cet été sur l' isf 2010
est là où est-ce qu'elle interviendra
sur les sf 2018 écoutez je j'ai peur
changement d'assiette la limitation à
l'immobilier n'est oublié je vous dis
tout de suite que j'ai peur de vous
répondre de manière inexacte mais comme
ne pas répondre n'est pas convenable jeu
j'ai tendance à penser que cela fera
partie du budget qui sera adoptée pour
2018 2010 et vous nous confirmer que
christian eckert a de bonnes raisons
d'être furieux contre vous puisque vous
re dès que vous décaler d'un an le
prélèvement à la source mais mais ça
fait longtemps monsieur eckert est
furieux emmanuel macron à dakar donc à
rien de changer pour lui en tous les cas
merci beaucoup
jean-francis voit la dernière partie de
l'épreuve de vérité maintenant écrit
qu'est la messe qui nous rejoint
maintenant
[Musique]
bonsoir mickaël michel bonsoir monsieur
faire en sorte de savoir quel président
sera emmanuel macron on a vu une image
fait quoi la découvrir ensemble
l'image du louvre d'ouvrir la marche
solitaire évidemment sur l'esplanade du
musée avec la pyramide dans laxe de la
tête du président élu pour son qu'est ce
qu'elle veut vivre de la soirée qu'elle
vous inspire cette image quand vous
l'avez découvert vous étiez sur place
j'imagine
est-ce que c'était ce côté mitterrandien
où c'était totalement l'opposé d'un
françois hollande août à nicolas sarkozy
d'abord c'est un marcheur
vous l'avez observé mais au-delà de ce
commentaire je crois que c'est une
certaine solennité qui correspondait à
un sentiment de joie empreinte de
gravité qui était ce que ressentaient
emmanuel macron c'est à dire qu emmanuel
macron a évidemment pris la mesure que
les françaises et les français ont mis
finalement beaucoup d'espoirs en lui et
en tout cas n'ont pas hésité quand on
vise les contradicteurs n'ont pas hésité
à évacuer ceux qui incarnent et une
certaine manière de faire de la
politique
donc il sent bien il sent bien que il a
sur lui une promesse mais une promesse
fondatrice à tenir qui est de rassembler
les françaises et les français
d'ailleurs il a dit combien elle était
conscient que madame le pen malgré ce
débat où elle a montré tant de haine et
tant d'incompétence elle a quand même
réussi à obtenir à temps un plus un peu
plus du tiers des voix donc c'est quand
même un souci que par ailleurs à temps
plein
après the race un président rassembleur
de bérulle donc bon 4 millions il faut
il faut en prendre compte richard
ferrand tenir compte part d'un président
jupiter ya c'est emmanuel macron qui
s'est décrit lui-même comme cela dans la
presse
ça veut dire quoi selon vous président
qui tranche qui prend les grandes
décisions
c'est comme ça que je le traduirait donc
ça veut dire aussi les tranches aussi
par rapport à ses prédécesseurs et c'est
ce que voulait dire en tout cas vu de
vous dire comment il serait lui je vous
laisse le soin de comparer leur est ce
que ça veut dire par exemple qu'il va
avoir beaucoup de 10
par rapport à la presse notamment par
rapport à sa façon d'entrevoir cette
présidence en gros ce qui va à l'elysée
on le voit plus les français le verrons
le journaliste peut être moins qu'avant
puisque tout de même vous savez il faut
bien prendre un peu de recul mais enfin
vous êtes plus qualifiés que pour le
faire mais en dix ans sur le quinquennat
de monsieur sarkozy hollande qui doivent
correspondre à peu près à l'émergence
des chaînes d'information et ses alliés
ne peut plus passer un événement sans
que le présent la république et sont
moins dire du moins juge utile de dire
son nom
une espèce d'ovni présence médiatique et
qui parfois assez peu signifiantes et
donc à partir de là le sens se perd la
capacité du chef de l'exécutif a donné
les grandes perspectives de son action
ces mousses et ça ça nuit et je vois qui
est manuel macron a le souci lui de
donner le sens d'expliquer les grands
choix qu'il fait mais qu'ensuite qu'il y
aura un gouvernement en somme vous
promener avec la présidence sarkozy de
la présidence hollande il faut faire
tous la version je sais pas si ça
suffira en tout cas faut faire dans les
deux cas pas ce qui a été fait en tous
les cas de la diète médiatique qu'est ce
que il n'y a pas eu un paradoxe étonnant
en 48 heures puisque effectivement vous
souligné qu'il y avait eu cette marche
solennelle du président tout juste élu
mais le lendemain on l'a retrouvé lui
mais sous l'arc de triomphe avec un
françois hollande qui l'a traité un peu
quand même comme un élève quoi vais pas
trouver avec ses gestes d'affection est
ce que vous avez été agacé vous
personnellement oui baron j'ai trouvé
que le président hollande était
bienveillant à voile a dit nous positif
c'était positif et mais même quand le
chef de l'état actuel encore quelques
jours indique qu'il a indiqué la marche
à suivre à emmanuel macron seuil et ils
sont riches je ne pense pas que ça ait
bouleversé les français grâce vous avez
pas vu le documentaire ou ce qu'on nous
en parle et michel tout à l'heure mais
il ya une phrase quand même qui fait
écho encore aujourd'hui il dit si vous
écoutez les mecs de la sécurité je le
cite vous finissez comme hollande
vous êtes mort oui est ce qu il a raison
pas bien sûr parce que emmanuel macron
ne souhaite pas être
un président en serre est enfermé dans
le palais de l'elysée d'ailleurs vous le
voyez bien dans ses déplacements de
ministres et même deux candidats et
parfois ça donne des images qui n'ont
pas toujours à son avantage mais il aime
aller au contact
voilà quand il déplacé communiste et
l'économie s'il y avait un piquet de
grève ou des gens qui manifestaient il
aller au contact
il va discuter il aime le contact direct
il aime la confrontation et surtout plus
que la confrontation la pédagogie
égouttez le ressenti des uns et des
autres s'entendre dire ce qui à leurs
yeux de nos concitoyens ne va pas et
leur apporter des réponses en prendre
note et c'est ce ne sera pas un
président médiatique ce sera un
président à l'écouté et à l'action il ya
encore des choses dont on a besoin de
savoir sur cette personnalité ce
président qu'il sera mbio graphique qui
sort dans les prochains jours deux
confrères françois-xavier bourmaud du
figaro il décrit aussi comme quelqu'un
qui a un côté très dur c'est quelqu'un
comme ça c'est quelque chose qu'on n'a
pas vu qu'on voit peu est-ce que vous
qui connaissez bien il a ce côté dur oui
c'est un homme très exigeant avec
lui-même et avec tous les autres surtout
lorsqu'il mesure que c'est pour servir
notre pays qu'il ya tout de même un
certain nombre de préoccupations
importantes et par conséquent oui il
sait être il sait être dû rendre il faut
être dur mais n'oubliez jamais ça dur
avec lui-même
oui et avec celles et ceux qui veulent
servir le pays nous par exemple quand il
dit où on laisse dire en tout cas tant
dans la presse qu'il a déjà prévenu des
hauts fonctionnaires après 250
fonctionnaires des hauts fonctionnaires
est bien évidemment qu'ils ne seraient
pas sur la même ligne que lui
hop on fait ménage non attention il n'a
pas dit ça comme ça il a dit simplement
que les hauts fonctionnaires qui sont
légitimes occuper leurs positions
doivent développer la culture du
résultat c'est à dire que tente un
ministre dira recevra les instructions
du premier ministre
pour dire voilà les objectifs atteindre
voilà à quelles dates de sortie et les
décrets les arrêtés de thé loi etc etc
si les choses se passent mal le ministre
pourra je pense est exemple c'est un
exemple
ce n'est pas une règle mais le ministre
pourra être révoqué tout comme un
directeur d'administration pour être
révoqué chasse aux sorcières n'ont pas
de chasse aux sorcières mais la culture
du résultat pas a priori jeu derrière il
n'est en train d'instaurer où il ne va
pas estoril un spoil si cela on 16
bien sûr que non qu'avait d'ailleurs
imaginer nicolas sarkozy mais je vais
vous donner deux exemples
il ya quelque chose ou un titre d'élu
local car ce n'est du territoire moi qui
m'ont qui m'ont toujours choquée vous
avez vous rappeler comment jean yves le
drian avait des difficultés sur le
logiciel ou voile au sujet de ce pays et
dvd univers milite les soldes des
militaires et la vivriers bruit dans
quel bourbier
nous sommes aujourd'hui au ministère de
l'agriculture s'agissant de payer les
primes pac ya à peu près deux ans de
retard alors le ministère et le ministre
le foll s'est débattue dans cette
difficulté fait des avances régulière
pour que les agriculteurs puissent
toucher à vous prouver 80% est repris et
on me dit que ce système informatique a
coûté plusieurs dizaines de millions
mais non une pipe je veux dire mais y
at-il eu des sanctions
voilà c'est ça que je vais vous donner
comme exemple des sanctions auprès des
personnes qui ont un moment donné juger
et donc mal jugé sur un choix
technologique qui s'avère coûteux
ruineux défaillant et inefficaces ou la
présidence de manuel mal à des sanctions
ben c'est ce rapport annuel de la cour
des comptes parce que des exemples comme
ça vous en avez je prends cela parce que
moi dans mon finistère tous les
agriculteurs m'en parle me disent mais
comment se fait-il que parfois les
primes pac de 2015 ne soit pas se lever
c'est incompréhensible si vous prenez
trois ans de retard pour payer vos
impôts ça va pas se passer comme ça donc
s'ils voulaient à un moment donné il
faut qu'on comprenne pourquoi il ya des
dysfonctionnements et pourquoi les
mauvaises décisions ont été prises il
faut sanction dure du résultat chère
faire je sais qu'on va retenir c'est la
journée
hop emmanuel macron aller voir angela
merkel à sion prochaine je sais que vous
parlez couramment allemand je vous ai vu
donner des interviews en allemand qu'est
ce qu'il doit dire
emmanuel macron angela merkel n'a que
vingt deux bords il ira ce qu'il voudra
je peux me permettre mois de vie dire ce
qu'il a à dire mes enfants
fondamentalement notre conviction c'est
quoi c'est que il va falloir urgemment
refonder l'europe que il faut que le
moteur franco-allemand se rallument pour
redonner ce souffle à l'europe
vous voyez bien que aujourd'hui alors
même que l'europe est extrêmement utile
dans de très nombreux domaines et bien
la perception que l'on concitoyens à nom
est négative
donc il va bien falloir un moment donné
que l'europe se remette à avancer
quitte à ce que cela se fasse par
cercles concentriques si je peux dire
est que ceux qui veulent pas bouger
n'empêche pas ceux qui veulent avancer
d'avancé est ce qu'elle incarne le rap
du passé selon vous qui ça un gala
merkel or vous savez il serait
extrêmement discourtois de juger un chef
de gouvernement étranger donc je ne le
ferais pas mais voilà merkel m'a paru
dans des circonstances extrêmement
compliqué être parfaitement à la hauteur
de sa tâche quand vous entendez le
président de la commission européenne
jean claude juncker dire aujourd'hui les
français dépensent trop et au mauvais
endroit
la raison vous en pensez quoi qu'est ce
qu'on pouvait lui dire parmi là il ya un
point sur lequel il a ses raisons
c'est-à-dire que nous n'investissons pas
assez et que le fonctionnement global de
l'action publique et fait plus
exactement que la dépense publique est
trop élevée face à un niveau
d'investissement qui lui est fait ils se
connaissent cette barre des 3%
évidemment du est-ce qu'il faut attendre
un acte de mansuétude au début du
quinquennat d'emmanuel macro ne la part
de nos amis européens mais un peut-être
même de denguin l'américaine avec quoi
je veux dire quelque chose vous aviez la
gentillesse de rappeler que j'avais
beaucoup d'amis allemands avec qui
j'échange régulièrement et c'est savez
pourquoi l'europe ça n'avance pas parce
que ça fait à peu près 15 ans que les
français en fument les allemands turcs
ont dit un acte de mansuétude nous
imposez pas votre rigueur budgétaire
etc mais en même temps il faudrait que
les allemands soient le bouclier
économique et monétaire de l'europe donc
les allemands eux ils veulent bien
retrouver le chemin de l'investissement
et de l'action collective à condition
d'avoir des partenaires un peu sérieux
et d'audrey fiable par conséquent moi
j'ai la conviction qu emmanuel macron
fera en sorte que la france redevienne
un partenaire crédible et fiable pour
les allemands mais pour l'ensemble des
partenaires de retour en europe
c'est ce que j'espère de tout coeur on
en montrant sa capacité à faire des
efforts elle-même bien sûr ce salon est
bien sûr il faut que est quand même
curieux que nous parvenons parvenions
pas à obtenir certaines certaines
évolutions certains changements
là où d'autres que l'on réussit le
problème c'est que c'est pas du confort
que l'on crée c'est du handicap pour
demain senger qu'aujourd'hui les
excédents allemands permettrait de
réaliser des plans d'investissement
extraordinaire pour l'allemagne mais il
ne peut pour l'europe pardon mais
aujourd'hui la réticence des enfants
mais que les partenaires ne leur
paraissent pas suffisamment fiables
dernière question d'actualité marion
maréchal annonce qu'elle va quitter tous
ses mandats ne va pas se représenter à
la députation dans le vaucluse et le
quittent la région paca
peut-être une forme de lassitude on ne
sait pas donc il n'y aura pas de
succession chez les le pen apparemment
comme on avait pu imaginer entre la
tante et la nièce une réaction ça vous
inspire quoi
une peine qui arrêtent de faire de la
politique moi ça ne me fâche pas puisque
si vous voulez on avait une dynastie
familiale qui depuis 40 ans était
présente à l'élection présidentielle
donc vouloir le renouvellement c'est
aussi faire en sorte qu'on n'ait pas une
pme de l'extrême droite qui prospèrent
trop voilà donc une bonne nouvelle pour
vous merci richard ferrand merci à vous
d'avoir été avec nous donc on va suivre
votre itinéraire personnel où est ce
qu'on va vous retrouver dans quelques
jours bientôt en campagne dans le
finistère dans le finistère et peut-être
également à paris quelque part merci
beaucoup à tous les cadets venus
aujourd'hui merci michael bonsoir à tous
à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]